olá hoje em falar sobre como tudo o
aquecimento global
o que podemos fazer por enfrentando para
começar eu vou falar do efeito estufa
o efeito estufa o processo quando há o
calor emitido pela superfície da terra é
absorvido pela atmosfera
o aquecimento global mesmo assim um
mecanismo necessário
o aquecimento global tem sido pouco
comentado pela ação humana ou seja estão
aumentando a emissão de gases na
atmosfera e aumentando o calor o que
provoca o efeito estufa vocês devem
estar se perguntando o que a gente
pagava os produtores de efeito estufa
são carbônico e vapor d'água que está de
queimadas uso de combustíveis fósseis
achei que não fosse um pouco de fez uva
o calor vai para a superfície da terra
ei que ele é absorvido pela atmosfera
o efeito estufa é ruim mas a tarde não
pois sim o efeito estufa
a vida não poderia existir pois ele
mantém nosso planeta aquecido e o
aquecimento global é ruim
sim pois é uma ameaça à vida animal e
vegetal consequência vida humana
podemos contribuir para reduzir o
aquecimento global
nós só vamos tomar algumas atitudes no
nosso dia a dia podem de maneira a
missão de casa ou seja diminuindo calor
na tela
pequenas atitudes que se todos fizerem
podem fazer grande diferença
só o esporte coletivo tomar banhos mais
curtos que esse quarto lixo plantar
árvores economizar água
esta quer explicar e e explicar um pouco
mais porque estão vendo que tem a imagem
certo e errado na roda estão gastando
mais do que eu gostaria no certo mas
quanto mais água gasta mais energia eu
gosto
ou seja estou gastando mais água energia
aqui e aqui estou gastando menos pois o
atleta não está ligada
muito obrigado por sua atenção